all right some breaking news to bring
you now and the chief palestinian
negotiator
said erica has died at the age of 65.
he was hospitalized last month after
contracting coronavirus
the palestinian liberation organization
said erica required special care due to
chronic health problems
he served as an advisor to palestinian
authority president mahmoud abbas
and had been the palestinians chief
negotiator in peace talks with israel
for two and a half decades
jamal el shail takes a look back at his
life
say barakat was a familiar face in
palestinian politics for four decades
and he saw tumultuous events from an
early age
he was 12 years old when israeli tanks
rolled into his hometown of jericho
in 1967 he witnessed a war that would
last just six days but would shape the
entire middle east
in the decades since for their part it
would inform the decisions he made for
the rest of his life
says he had to grow up quickly under
israeli occupation in the west bank
his first arrest at the age of 13 was
not his last
he attended university in the united
states and moved to england to complete
a phd in conflict resolution
it was the beginning of his fight for
palestinian statehood through
negotiation
advocating a two-state solution based on
the 1967 borders
it was a compromise and a major
concession but throughout his life
israelis would accuse him of being an
extremist and sowing division
while palestinians would call him a
traitor to the palestinian cause
giving away too much at the madrid peace
talks in 1991 he insisted on wearing the
kofiya
the symbol of palestinian national
identity he was a hero to many back home
but at the conference it caused the stir
two years later he was left out of the
final talks on the oslo accords
negotiated by palestinian leader yasser
arafat
would rise to become the chief
palestinian negotiator in 1995
resigning only for a time in 2003
reportedly in protest of the palestinian
leadership at the time
his strength was as the public face for
the palestinian cause
communicating across language barriers
to explain their position to the
english-speaking world
while also an acceptable voice of the
palestinian liberation organization to
israel
but over the years he has described a
growing pessimism at israel's failure to
deliver on its undertakings
at the building of yet more illegal
israeli settlements increasing number of
checkpoints
brutality against palestinians and the
israeli separation war
now more than 700 kilometers long
peace talks he would say were out of
sync with the reality for palestinians
on the ground
he remained loyal to arafat even through
his power struggle with mahmoud abbas
who is now
president of the palestinian authority
such was arakat's popularity as a
politician he held on to his seat in the
2006 elections when hamas won by a
landslide
but with hamas in power and benjamin
netanyahu as israeli prime minister
the chances for an agreement waned
three wars on gaza followed arakat
described it as the new dark
age saying that leaving the middle
east's most emotive conflict unresolved
was simply fueling a regional descent
into chaos and extremism
he turned his attention to the united
nations and was instrumental in the
successful campaign to gain observer
status for the state of palestine within
the u.n
throughout arakat remained convinced
that the two-state solution based on the
1967 borders was still possible
the real alternative to a state of
palestine living side by side the state
of israel
in peace and security on the 1967 lines
is one democratic secular state where
jews muslims and christians can live
equal
with equal votes those who believe
that they can undermine the two-state
solution
and replace it with what i call one
state two systems
maintaining the status quo now upper
side
i don't think in the 21st century
they will get away with it it's
impossible
it was amongst the most critical voices
of the u.s sponsored normalization deals
which saw the united arab emirates and
bahrain establish full ties with israel
he described the deal as the birth of
arab zionism
and said the agreement was like a
poisoned dagger stabbed into the
palestinians back
sayi barakat fought for an agreement
between israelis and palestinians for
decades
but for his last years he was fighting
his own battle
lung disease kept at bay by an
experimental drug
eventually he would need a transplant of
both lungs
in 2007 he said he would hate to be a
grandfather living under occupation
he wasn't able to change that